[Music]
hello hello how are you doing my name is
Adam love going I like good music David
ingmar sitting to my left you can call
me right but I'm always left anyway hi
if you're listening to this podcast that
means that David ingmar and I are in
Lake Tahoe oh yeah
Lake Tahoe is in Utah it's Nevada I
think kind of that like we're gonna be
in Lake Tahoe we're gonna be at I
believe it's like the biggest celebrity
golf tournament in the world yeah I
can't believe that they can get this
many big names into one like wrangled
into one location on one great
incredible kind of like bigger than the
ESPYs in a way I think it's the the
tournament that when you see the video
of like Aaron Roger is throwing a pass
to a guy on a boat and like Steph Curry
I think it's that tournament oh nice so
they hit me up a while to go and and so
we're gonna try and get as many
interviews as we can for the next few
weeks kind of have fun with it
but we wanted to record a podcast we're
doing this on Tuesday and we're gonna do
a little bit of am a little ask us
anything and we're gonna have interviews
coming up in a little bit with Marcus
Mariota and Soni Michelle I have no idea
if they're gonna be good or not they're
brought to you by Gatorade I'm recording
this intro before we do them but I know
they're gonna be awesome I'm I'm
literally I'm gonna make sure that
they're fun I gonna tell Mariota that
he's the number one ranking in your your
stepdad rankings with it I am now thank
you for that producing that's good
producing right now I'll tell them that
and then I'll also kind of see I'll tell
him that I had them top ten in grill
rankings yeah mmm 10 that might get him
talking more but I just love just no
context just be like so we're on with
the number one stepdad in the NFL Marcus
Mariota how's it going and just hear
best part two is it's on the phone so
he's gonna be like
all right so before we get into the ask
me anything
I did see a whoa big offseason that I
want to talk about really quick and it
was just Lane Johnson about Carson Wentz
I had to get some Eagles lovin there
said Carson he's really on a different
mental state than he's ever been about
to do some big things this season
I think this thus far this offseason a
lot of people have bought into the
Mitchell true Biscay train which we
talked about on Tuesday's podcast and
right now it's really unsettling to me
that the Eagles are the media steam like
Mena Kimes came on this show Lewis
Riddick went online and said Carson
Wentz has his pick for MVP do you think
it's flipped from the underrated to
overrated thing like hey no one's
talking about the Eagles and then once
30,000 media members say no one's
talking about the Eagles clearly
everyone's talking my greatest fear
right now is that Sports Illustrated is
gonna say the Eagles are your Superbowl
champions like that's my fear right I
don't think those teams ever win unless
you pick the Patriots every year and
then you have a really good chance but I
am very curious about this year of
Carson Wentz I think the combination of
being called out in the media by a few
members of the Eagles combined with
signing a contract and thus protecting
yourself it's gonna be a big year very
excited can I jump in with one of the
first am a question yeah yeah they were
to us this is from @s black 1984 he asks
besides the Eagles who would you be
quote okay with winning the Superbowl
let me pull up the teams pull the teams
how about let me while I look this up
who are the teams do you root for any
other team than the Patriots no I mean
the Patriots are my team man FC team
like some people do that that's the
thing I actually am a big Jimmy
Garoppolo guy right they was right he
was such a stud you know like for a few
years you and your mind went he's the
replacement right and I spent like two
and a half years thinking like oh this
is the guy I'm gonna root for for the
next 15 years once Tom Brady decides to
hang up his cleats and that's that's
gonna be awesome so I I have that
connection to him a little Jacoby
Brissette in that element to write that
maybe Jacoby reset gets a team and all
the rooting for him so if I had an NFC
team this year will be the 49ers I don't
think they're gonna necessarily win the
Superbowl but right that's the team I
got my eye on as like hey if they could
sneak out 9 and 7
I'll be rooting for them on wildcard
weekend I do love the 49ers we've grown
very close to that fan base over the
last few years or and great fan base
Kittel just chugging beers after a Super
Bowl title will be great and I think the
other team I'm cool with and they're a
favorite is the Colts there's just
something about this Frank Reich Andrew
Luck team that were like Chris Ballard
where everything is done with good
intent and I know this cannot be rubbing
you the right way like I'm realizing it
as I'm saying yeah you're fine
keep your the rivalry between the paint
like do you hate that paint the Colts
when it was Peyton Manning versus Brady
I felt like they were on Monday night
what about what the whole like in
deflategate like they're always the team
that was like the reporters came with
the Patriots if it was the sort of thing
where that had led us down a down spiral
and Brady and Belichick blew up and Seth
Wickersham ended the dynasty right there
then yes I would be bitter about that
but they went on to win another couple
of Super Bowls and you know like at a
certain point you're such a charmed
sports fan that you just drop all the
hate right get it
so I guess my reason is I would imagine
luck on the parade similar to like Kawhi
we're like Kawhi did the a hole and
everyone laughed
I feel like Andrew Luck in a moment of
joy he would cry like he would quote
like J I don't know who's a really
famous Arthur a famous author Chuck
Klosterman your guy dammit wasn't ready
fun fact about Frank Reich I would like
to know from fact only quarterback in
NFL history to be undefeated in the
playoffs with more than one game he's
doing what he's doing out in the
playoffs in his life to him and that
cool love that guy alright I'm gonna go
to a question a response from the
Instagram story let's see what we got
let's see we got alright this is for
both of us Ethan M Baxter what is the
largest animal you could beat in a
fistfight hmmm largest animal I could
beat in a fist fight you know there are
some large ones that I wouldn't want to
get into a fistfight with but I probably
could win right like I think I could
beat a dog but that's what no one wants
to say they could beat a dog I'm Way
ahead right now let me punch it right in
the face oh my god if this is blue
sport life or death if that's the
question like if there's a cheetah
coming at you and you have to serve I
don't think I could survive a show
there's no chance and I would also say
that it depends on the dog have you ever
heard that thing it's like would you
rather fight one horse-sized duck or a
hundred duck-sized horses yeah I'm
afraid of the massive amounts of them
right there just Gracchus I just go that
one game of thrones were like he's being
swallowed up by I don't want to feel
that yes I'm gonna get claustrophobic
and my ask so what's your answer is a
biggest like Newfoundland dog um I
believe that the biggest animal that I
could beat is your standard golden
retriever yeah it's also it's
interesting that they said fistfight
because I don't know if the dog is that
hearing to the rules of a fistfight
yeah can they not bite me I think the
dog is going after your jugular and the
way that dogs do that's like in their
DNA right I'm going for that joke that's
fine my friend you're in a bite foam
yeah it's not a fun thing to say out
loud when you realize you're now on
microphone willfully talking about
beating up a dog if the dog was
attacking me if the dog were attacking
you it's in self-defense that's fine
what was yours the animal that I could
beat up you know I do have like my
friends if they're ever listening to
this are gonna like die laughing because
I have this like infamous history where
I like fought off a group of pigeons
really at one point like they were just
circling around my air conditioner right
outside my bedroom window and just oh oh
till three four or five in the morning
continued and I know it sounds stupid
and funny but like week three where you
can't sleep it's not funny anymore
you're a psychotic New Yorker at that
point and I had to do anything possible
so I actually got some nyquil and I
spread it on some Wheat Thins and fed it
yeah both implicated ourselves alive
what happened they did not come back I
don't know if they are deceased but they
did not come back Wow
I had an itch situation at the beach
where I was like holding a sandwich and
this seagull came down and tried to rip
it from my hand and I pulled it back and
like he stared at me and I almost fought
the seagull at the beach oh my god it's
terrifying okay so no interest in
fighting him just learning a lot about
us right there all right what's next
from the Twitterverse this is a football
one not
a silly one yeah at Kevin laughs k112
says realistically who has the brighter
future going forwards true Biscay or
deshaun Watson uh Watson hmm I think
that I like Maggie more than Bill
O'Brien but I believe that deshaun
Watson is a player that can win a Super
Bowl on his own like he's the one of
those special players that can make
magic happen and going like a Russell
Wilson type run and just win three
playoff games on his back and true
Biscay is someone that i think is a
little bit more offense dependent I
thought it was interesting
defensive end pass rusher for the
Bengals I think it was Carl Lawson said
that he thinks it's actually easier to
sack Aaron Rodgers than anybody else and
I read the full quote and in the quote
he said that it's because Aaron Rodgers
is gonna wait for that guy to get open
cuz he knows that let he's gonna Pat the
ball he goes now we were up by two and a
half touchdowns on the air Rodgers he
came back and beat us but I got two and
a half sacks
he said it's harder to sack a guy like
try Biscay because the offensive
coordinator protects him that's where we
still are with true Biscay sure we've
never had that with the Shaun Watson but
I think if Victor played at some point
like then we find out he's this whole
different quarterback we weren't
expecting I believe that when you are
the superstar talent and the
restrictor-plate never goes on it comes
on later in your career later in our
career we go to Andrew Luck and say stop
running so [ __ ] much later in the
career we go to Carson Wentz and say
start protecting your body
deshaun Watson got sacked last year more
than any quarterback in the NFL they're
not protecting him at all he's doing
whatever he needs to they're giving him
room to improvise the Mitchell true
Biscay has been much like Jared Goff put
into a certain path and he's executed
very well in that path I believe it's
harder to get a true Biscay to do a
Watson than it is for Watson to do a
true Biscay if that makes sense
I would love to hear your your your
buddy Warren sharps take on all of this
because when you see numbers of sacks at
the end of the year and it's like oh
Aaron Rodgers got sacked 24 times and
this guy got sacked 18 and that means
that in the other but I'd love to hear
Warren Warren Sharpe sort of breakdown
of like was it a system sack and that
like because Aaron Rodgers got sacked
slightly more he actually was able to
throw this many more
it's you know Pro Football Focus
actually does a good job of charting
like water sacks or what our coverage
sacks right quarterback sacks and
they'll put sacks on the quarterback if
it's on them but anytime you see a team
like the Houston Texans reach on an
offensive tackle in the first round
because one just got taken and then
reach again in the second round on
another offensive tackle that's really
all you need to know about where they
thought those sex were coming from right
their offensive line they traded Dwane
Brown to the Seahawks two seasons ago
because he was saying all those comments
about the owner our IP and they just
they haven't been able to figure it out
right but and Bill O'Brien still wants
to run the same Patriots offense without
Dantes Carnegie it's not going to work
all right
IG one if you were to rob a bank yeah oh
I love high stuff yes which member of
the heist squad would you be so do your
typical anger inventory right are the
members of a high squad you've
definitely got the wheel man right
driver yeah you've got the the grease
man according to Ocean's eleven the guy
that can sneak into small places oh
right that's very very you've got the
the Danny ocean who's just sort of
putting it all together yeah yeah you
know who I would be though is the guy
that is unflappable able to talk to
people without you know without giving
anything away I've got a little sort of
an acting improv so you're the
distractor yeah well it's just it's the
guy that can that can just walk right in
and talk to the bank manager and be like
hey I'd like to talk to you about you
know I got to take a look at your vault
you know I'm I'm buying my wife some
nice jewelry for her birthday and I look
at though I need to see so you open the
vault with your mouth yeah I'm just I'm
not a chat guy I would be the slightly
out of shape fake heart attack distract
guy oh yeah that's all you gotta be
another thirty forty years because I'm
not slipping into anything if you talk
to my family and friends you don't want
me behind the wheel okay
not my wheel man no I could also be a
really good everybody get on the ground
like I could hit that okay really well
that's a different kind of college is to
all the listeners that's a different
kind of Bank
that's more of the town than Ocean's
eleven that shows how much more prepared
you are because I was I wasn't prepared
for this question at all but at any
moment I am prepared to discuss heists
at a very high I'm not looked at any no
we haven't but I will bust out you know
what you need yeah I was thinking in the
town oh you were thinking oceans la casa
del papel the Spanish language series
that's on Netflix they call her house
yes they called it money heist when they
translated into English for some reason
it's a 22-episode heist it's
unbelievable you wouldn't think that
it's able to sustain it Wow as a series
it's incredible highly recommended all
right heist heist knowledge subtitle
soldier yeah I watch I pay more
attention to sometimes don't watch it
with the English dubbing because it's
very distracting the acting is so good
in Spanish alright to Twitter we go
alright at Harvey 100 Mary [ __ ] kill
Kirk Cousins Eli Manning Blake bortles
these are so weird
you could just marry all of them if you
want you can uh friends with all them
whatever you want to do Kirk Cousins Eli
Blake plates gone it's just a sorry
damn no I'm gonna take that back you
don't want to do it no I think I'm gonna
marry Kirk oh great yeah hey you gonna
teach him at a grill and then I think
I'm gonna kill Eli okay you heard it
here first
damn it's such a I don't like to quit
it's weird that's fair alright would you
ever have this is from Luka Oh leus
would you ever have one of the 33%
homies on the show yes and I will also
make a formal announcement we are going
to do the left coast show fantasy league
again this year and that's one of the
questions great I think that was another
question too so whether this is meatball
Henry or excuse me
meatloaf Henry or anybody else that
wants to organizes again we had nearly
400 people sign up last year I think
there's a lot of fun remember we had one
of the homie 33% who won the league come
on to the show and do 5 to 10 minutes
and I think also as we do more shows on
the road as those are kind of popping up
we're gonna do some live AMAs and stuff
so you guys really going to come on the
show but I think yeah my main thing is
the guy that wins the fantasy league is
definitely coming on when we hit on the
road you guys can come on and
maybe if you guys want to send me some
questions that you think are really
funny whether it's video of it maybe
it's in the left coast show DMS on
Instagram because that way I can just
kind of get them maybe we'll play some
on the show and we're just gonna make
that on the fly right there you just
produce the show thank you perfect
appreciate it we got two questions that
are on the same theme now okay okay this
is a tangelo formato asks the NFL QB
rankings for most likely to survive on a
desert island and then at Liam Owen 30
says if you had to survive on an island
with one NFL player who would it be so
that's kind of a similar theme there so
the first one I think I kind of answered
that that one I feel very similar the
rankings to the what was that movie that
we did a thing on oh the Hunger Games
Hunger Games yeah so for me it's like
the carson wentz
it's like Carson wins because I think
he's gonna help me survive yep and he's
such a giving guy I mean he literally
has a food truck that serves the
homeless in that situation that would be
me so I would need him to feed me but
what if we go non cubies just anyone in
the NFL is now fair game I'm assuming
coaches are fair game I'm assuming
broadcasters are fair game who would you
who would help you survive on a desert
island so I think that there's two
questions there's one who's gonna help
me survive and there's two who would you
want to hang out with for an unlimited
amount of time with no other distraction
if I found out that fish and coconuts
and water we're easy to come by and now
it's just a want to hang out in the
teepee with ya
I would love to kick it with Kelsey I
would love to kick it with Kittel I
think tight ends I believe might have
the best personality because they're
reasonable like offensive lineman but at
the same point they're a little bit
flashy like a wide receiver okay and
yeah they have a nice little mix I'm
gonna I'm going to annoy most of these
people that's really the issue -
interesting yeah so I'm also trying to
figure out who kind of likes me already
and would tolerate mm-hmm so that's part
of it how about you I think I'd want to
hang with McVeigh Sean McVeigh he just
seems like a cool hang she's young
asking him questions oh yeah and that's
the thing like he would be like he would
memorize the layout of the island on the
first few hours and then he'd he'd know
which berries you could eat he would
just he would have
and never get where something was that's
what that's great yeah
where was that palm tree with those
delectable coconut that's a value-add 17
paces to the left yes um okay man a lot
of f mary kills that's a yeah it's a
it's an it's a standard trope of AMAs
who would win in a sumo fight Quintin
Nelson or Trent Brown oh I am gonna go
quit Nelson because I believe in sumo a
lot of it is leverage yes and I believe
that the height that Trent Brown has
will actually be a distraction and that
Quinton will be able to get underneath
him and toss him out of them yeah I
don't think I some does have longer arms
I do imagine some amount of height is
helpful in sumo and then at a certain
point it flips where you don't want that
much height anymore and you're actually
someone's able you get up under you
which is true of offensive lineman in a
way sometimes I think and everybody
knows I love Trent Brown
but quittin Nelson Trent Brown has a lot
of weight Quinton Nelson is compact and
he's like a fire hydrant and when when
people that I know have been around
Trent Brown they go isn't he big when I
know out of the football players they've
been around Quinton Nelson they go I've
never seen anyone built like that where
it's like the traps and the PEC muscles
its he's he's not as like cut as Aaron
Donald but it's like very well placed
300 pounds or even more I'm taking quit
Nelson yeah I think I would go with
Quinn Nelson - you want another question
yeah yeah yeah this is from at G Mills
for do you understand basic economics I
don't know if that's a dig or if it's
just a question he's interested in Oh
that is probably a response to my NBA
NFL rant I don't know yeah the thing
about the whole MBA and a foul rant was
as if you listen to the actual podcast I
am NOT saying that NFL players should be
paid as much as NBA players
I was just spotlighting the disparity
between how much money they make on a
yearly basis yeah sometimes there's
there's a difference between saying
there needs to be a systemic change
versus just I'm just laying out facts
because they're interesting I'm doing I
think you were much more the latter in
that it's it's really interesting what
I've learned
working in the sports opinion space is
that everyone knows I call it the
irrefutable evidence fandom thing that's
not what I call it it when you're
watching a football game and there's a
[ __ ] replay yeah and your friend
looks at you and goes the call on the
field was incomplete and they need
excuse me
indisputable video evidence right return
it you look at your friend and go an oh
[ __ ] I've watched football before and
I've heard Troy Aikman say that a
thousand times
yeah Cris Collinsworth is all about yes
we know we and and when someone says
that I go it's implied I understand that
but it's good that you can as a human
hear something and then re say it at a
later date there are certain debates
that people find a little bit of
information on and they're obsessed with
letting you know that they have that
information hmm
there's more people on an NFL roster an
oh [ __ ] is that true they play more
games than the NBA an oh [ __ ] right and
but what happens is they go I know a
fact and you go obviously I know that
fact too but thank you for presenting
that fact right so so ever since that
video came out it's been very fun to
hear all the facts that everybody knows
it's really great but the I call it the
indisputable video evidence well while
we're on the topic of indisputable
evidence I feel like well just just the
idea that when there is a call that
needs to be overturned
it's either indisputable or it's not and
if you have to watch five minutes worth
of replay it's clearly disputable very
point regardless of whether the like a
quarter of a blade of grass touched the
ball under the guy's hand like if you
couldn't see that until it was in
SuperDuper crazy slow-mo on the
eighteenth replay like that Julian
Edelman on that punt where they thought
it might have hit his thumb and they
wash it like four minutes I feel like
since if you're gonna call it
indisputable evidence is required then
you should be able to watch it twice at
pretty much regular speed and everyone
at home goes oh yeah he stepped out of
bounds
oh yeah the ball hit the ground cool
look cuz we see those replays like done
why are we why are we still watching I
have not spent any time on this because
I know that we're gonna be spending a
lot of time
this during the season but when there's
like less than 2 minutes left and
they're looking to see how much hand
went on from a corner back to a wide
receiver and they're deciding what's
pass interference it's gonna be awful
yeah I mean I don't even want to talk
about it right now because the to me
it's what we did in the preseason last
year talking about the leading with the
head hits and how that took over the
news cycle sure that's happening this
year
mhm those those weeks one through three
in the preseason it's gonna be awful
former lawyers are gonna have a field
day on TV talking about that kind of
[ __ ] I just got what I'm stealing one of
yours from Twitter please
it just says more details on your news
show yeah I don't know what we're
allowed to divulge at this stage yeah
whatever you want well I mean I just
don't I don't wanna like ditch the
PlayBook right now and like kind of get
everything out there I will say what the
new show is gonna be is gonna be it's
gonna be like eight episodes during the
season yes and they're gonna be YouTube
episodes if you watch The Sims and Lefko
the show last year it was kind of like a
studio show where we did a bunch of
different segments this one every
episode is gonna be about a different
player yeah and we're gonna be doing
things in the field with these players
that are very fun all them are related
to football but deeper dives that you
haven't really seen before I don't want
to give away any of the episodes we're
gonna be shooting a lot but it's sort of
like man if the left go show is me
interviewing Quinton Nelson this YouTube
show will be me doing things with
Quinton Nelson yeah that's I think the
most I want to get into it but without
giving away things is that classic show
don't tell ya and then that's what it's
literally gonna be yeah
showing that Talley at talking td's he
asks out of all your guests since
becoming the left go show who would win
the Royal Rumble because you've had some
tough dudes on this so this has just
become in the left coast show this is
not including Sims and left right then
the name that popped into my mind I
don't know if you got if you want to say
yours first but I hear yours I think
Colette she is is a tough out in
I think Colette she would take down
Trent Brown and those are really like to
it like I think Jonathan Abram would
fight until my but he's like more in the
like Iceman Dean Malenko yeah wrestling
category like you know Colette she he's
the Undertaker if he turned it on I
don't think a lot of people are getting
in his way that's what I'm saying
yeah maybe Warren Sharpe you think
welcome what if Warren Sharpe is like
secretly like a triple black belt and
knows all of like the instant dead
points that was the thing you know in
the sequel to The Hunger Games right
where it was all these former champions
and two of them were these very bookish
nerds they didn't have any fighting
skills but they could like wire up some
weird electricity and beat the other
people that way maybe that's Warren
sharps um hello she's like you're mine
and then like takes a step and then
explodes like Super Smash Brothers and
when she was wearing some weird jet
propulsion pack that allows him to fly
around odd that you didn't see that why
are there I figured you would with a
great awareness yeah I'd probably go
Colette you too if you have everybody
wants me to fight or have sex with
people
next time we ask for a mas this is say
we're fighting insects I guess um PP
Shump dur Schumpeter are you still in
contact with Sims how do you cope with
the loss will he see him on me and Sims
text somewhat regularly I think the
truth for most people that you'll learn
is when you're in high school you go to
college you don't talk to many of your
high school friends because you're busy
all the time with college when you go
from college to professional same thing
we we text every now and then if
something from his show that I like pops
into my timeline I'll hit him up be like
oh nice job or if I got an interview
then he sees it that I was wishing his
brother a happy birthday
I'm you know we're we go back and forth
he just got a new house so I was
congratulating him on that how do I cope
with it if I was gonna let you guys
behind the curtain I was able to cope
with it all throughout December in
January because that's kind of what I
knew was gonna happen was in December so
like I was dealing with the realization
in December in January so by the time I
was ready to kind of do the left go show
I had gotten a lot of it out of my
system because it sucks because the
thing that I always tell people it's not
that I was like oh it's more work or oh
I want to keep talking to Sims it's more
like I got to see my guys everyday and
you know like it's fun to hang out with
you everyday fun it was fun to hang out
with Sims you know I mean like you just
they're your friends so for me the thing
that I really tried to do is sit down a
lot and go what do I want the show to be
not how do I keep this thing running but
what if I was gonna make this more
myself why would I want it to go and so
being able to kind of sit down and try
and come up with ideas and a direction
that allows you to cope with anything
because then you get into the creative
process and you're like let's keep doing
that [ __ ] and to be honest the homies
and the 33% rallying the way they did
making me feel like a goddamn king all
the time and and reaching out to you
guys and saying who do you want on this
guest and be able to get the fantasy
footballers in Kyle brand Nate Burleson
and Mina caves like we're running down
that list being able to like deliver
that [ __ ] is very rewarding yeah because
even for me I'm like you like I'll hit
on people they're like I would be
honored I'm like you're honored I
thought I was reaching out I wasn't
gonna get a response people like being
asked to do stuff I'm continually
impressed when you reach out to like NFL
players or other media members and
you're like hey would you do this
podcast and I like no yeah yeah oh yeah
people like to be asked to do stuff it's
weird to like when people come in
they're like man I've really been
enjoying your [ __ ] I'm like you watch my
[ __ ] God pay attention to things that
matter and I just like to add I continue
to text Chris Sims as much as I did
before I got this job yeah
which is never we've always been you
want this one from app mr. Rogers story
ooh if you could choose any city to get
a new NFL franchise where would it be
and what would the team name be let me
pull up the city's oh yeah like what
city what's what's it what's a nice
juicy city that deserves an NFL team
that would be great for road trips that
would be a great fan base built in like
I just I think Vancouver so here is a
bleep interesting
that's interest I mean like who doesn't
want another Pacific Northwest team so I
looked up bleacher report of course has
a list
the ten cities that are the biggest that
do not have an NFL team at number one
was Los Angeles so this is clearly a
little bit dated
but the option is to San Antonio Texas
Las Vegas Nevada was three so they're
getting one Columbus Ohio
Orlando Omaha Nebraska do sakharova high
team that's a great idea
Portland Oregon Norfolk Virginia Salt
Lake City Utah I think which one Omaha
is interested just because the
Nebraskans they're obsessed with go nuts
yeah I love your idea of Vancouver I
think Toronto has opened up a lot of
eyes with the NBA title I also think
about teams like Mexico City yeah that's
that the international stuff is really
and then everyone always talks his
London gonna get a team I mean I love
the idea of Vancouver just because a lot
of people in like Seattle Portland
whatever can take a nice cool road trip
yeah Vancouver and see a you know if
you're if your team is in town that
weekend Mexico City I feel like is a
more of a commitment if you're gonna
have to fly there from somewhere else
but yeah if they have enough NFL fans
down there to sustain the team that's
cool I say go international I'm gonna
pick Oakland Oakland yeah yeah cuz third
teams going to Vegas so you want to
replace it yeah I think they should like
Seattle getting an NBA team back at some
point oh man the NFL would never do that
just like the NBA will never do no but
I'm saying like there's that court a
pang of nostalgia yes you know certain
people that just want you know Seattle
got robbed of its amazing Sonics and
that that's a franchise city that
deserves an NBA team and maybe one day
knock on wood we'll get one I think st.
Louis can have an NFL team again - sure
I know those were I mean shoot it's fun
it's interesting that you mentioned st.
Louis because they this question also
asked what would you name the team and
there was an NBA team or maybe an ABA
team but there's an NBA team for a while
a basketball team that was named the
spirit of st. Louis it was like the team
name came before the city which I
happened before it wasn't like the New
York Knicks it was the spirit of st.
Louis which I just think is so cool yeah
as a team name it's so hard to come up
with a truly innovative cool team name
if anyone's gonna come with the cool
team names it's you it's not me so
anyway the sort
you were going to Vancouver what would
the team name be oh boy that's such a
great question so they got the Canucks
they had the Grizzlies for a while and
that became the Memphis Grizzlies I need
to I want to learn more I'd wanted I'd
want to spend an hour fielding for
Cougars sure I'd what would the London
teen name be because this is something
that people talk about the time if
London got a football team yeah what
would they be called the guard the
palace guard the London guard is a
phenomenal [ __ ] name wouldn't it be
cool I love tea names that don't have an
S at the yeah it's the trivia question
we've all I answered it's the heat it's
the magic if it's the London guard ah
and then think about like all the cool
posters and t-shirts you could have if
they have a sick defense what if it was
the London Eye the eyes good too and
then it's like a like us always watching
you it's like one of it but it's the
look it's the helmet is the eye from
Lord of the Rings hmm so it's like that
burning fiery orange
hasar on the London guard is really good
not bad I just add that by the way it's
not old material I just one of ingmar
strengths is thinking of names on the
spies that you think the word London you
start rattling off okay like Tower of
London Buckingham Palace touted at it so
I just went to Buckingham Palace guard
and I thought hey you know they like
they kind of have the color scheme of
the Buckingham Palace guard the red and
black would look sick yeah oh my god
would be we got something
if you could be the brother of one NFL
coach I love it would it be this is
Tanner Malin the brother of a coach and
you have to think who's gonna give me
the best benefit if you're Belichick's
brother he's not bringing you into the
facility unless he's working you to the
bone right you kind of need to find the
cool guy now if you're a brother of John
and Jay now you're the third Gruden
brother and you're the only one not
coaching awkward Thanksgiving
what about yeah Harbaugh Ryan brothers
you join a brother group already you're
the Cooper Manning and now you're the
one that's not following the path
understood I would love to be Mike
Tomlin's brother mmm in multiple ways
but I just think he'd be a guy that
would kind of let you coach the wide
receivers for a day which I feel like
would be a blast
I would be Andy Reid's brother just
because I would love every like every
photo opportunity we get we wear the
same Hawaiian shirt and then that
becomes our stick right we're just we're
always wearing silly bright crazy luau
shirts and it's like hello Dave and Andy
Reid always always wearing their shirts
at the luau I love that one a lot
Zimmer is too intense to be my brother
Patricia would blame me for things I
would love to be Sean Peyton's brother
Cho definitely because I just see Sean
Payton getting done with practice
lighten up a stogie passing you one pour
in your little glass of bourbon and
being like wide receivers right you're
like [ __ ] I just eyes Sean baton would
be a great did you mention variable
variables too intense i would write more
of the Sean Payton Bruce Arians than the
variable Brian flora no but I think
variable has that like real intense
during the game and super chill before
and after I think I think you don't get
feel it's all run in wind sprints before
games yeah dude dude stay in shape yeah
I don't like guys that stay in shape
Bruce Arians Bruce Arians literally is
like if you're if your wife has a
recital that she needs to go to then you
leave work and you go to it like Bruce
Arians cares a lot about family so
that's why I feel like maybe he might be
the best we should point out that if you
and I were NFL coaches we would still
put in like 40 hour weeks we wouldn't we
wouldn't be doing the like hundred and
twenty hour weeks that people are like
it was like hey wait how did you name me
the NFL coach you knew what you were
getting into would you break down second
down from the 15-yard line I know I
figured one of my assistants would be
this guy Warren Sharpe that's the thing
you could hire your guys I would try to
cuz I'm not doing it all you got another
one over there yet dream guests from at
pay and I don't know how to pronounce
that at pangur dream guess let's go up
and back here Aaron Rodgers is my number
one numero uno but my my issue is I've
said this before if I got Aaron on I
wouldn't even know where to start I feel
like every podcast has a thing like that
like I listen to a lot of Chris Hardwick
podcast back in the day he talked about
how Steve Martin was his number one com
idle but that if he ever got him on he
would just kind of freeze up and look
you know where do I even start because
you just want to go what's it like to be
amazing yeah you know just do that for
an hour do the Chris Farley show exactly
remember when you threw that Hail Mary
that was awesome
so Aaron Rodgers what about like if they
walked in would you text your wife and
go holy [ __ ] this person's in here today
doesn't have to be football related uh
it could also be Tom Brady yeah I mean
Tom Brady I feel like I've heard every
interview Tom Brady's done except I
missed that beer-chugging one which I
still blame my friends for not having
seen ya tell though it was too late I
just like I think um you had Julian
Edelman here I'm just running through
like great Patriot those are the PLO
check is in my top five yeah Belichick
would be mainly because even if you
wouldn't get him to open up that's
amazing but but here's the deal if you
get if Rogers or Belichick ever came on
the pot that means that they had to have
okayed it mhm
because Rogers typically doesn't do
sports podcasts and Belichick never does
any media I saw him do one video one
time with like an MSNBC and it was
because it was all about the Navy and he
was like he'll do Navy or lacrosse but
if he was willing to sit down with me
that means that he's willing to go down
that room but to me it would be the most
fun to try and read him and to try and
figure out where he would want to go and
that there are just not a lot of humans
that are that challenging and the good
thing too is like if Belichick doesn't
answer my questions and walks out that's
what he does to everybody right I'm just
one of everybody then yeah so I'm trying
to think through it in terms of like who
would have the coolest stories mmm who
have I not heard enough from mmm right
cuz like I said with Brady Brady's done
a lot of interview he's did the entire
Facebook series he did there really
isn't anything we don't know about him
at this pool so even though he's to me
the goat he's my favorite Patriot of all
time this that and the other yeah I
would go with someone like bo Jackson
bo Jackson is a podcast guest he sit him
down he must just have Story upon story
everyone knows him everyone looks up to
him yeah he's one of the great what if
athletes of our lifetime Deion Sanders
is up there for me to sure you talked
about like story tellers oh yeah I would
love to get
old classic teammates together mmm
that's I would love to get a Deon and
Michael together I would love to get a
Steve Young Joe Montana together and
that would be kind of awkward but like
yeah that whole thing would be like such
a cool dynamic I would love to get Jerry
Jones the thing that was that I'm when
I'm thinking about it the thing that
sucks about when you interview a guy
like Jerry Jones is there is these
questions that as a media guy you think
you have to ask and all I want to talk
to Jerry Jones about is partying like
that's what I would just want to be like
man what's it like to bit make your
money on oil you know like that has to
be [ __ ] crazy you're just like drill
over there oh [ __ ] like that's another
billion what was that first day like
when you tapped oil you know but
everyone be like talking about the code
of conduct and I just don't want to talk
about that you see what I thought you
were gonna say is that when you
interview someone like Roger Goodell or
Jerry Jones or someone that's at that
level like even if you were to interview
Barack Obama
it would be so sanctioned the questions
that you'd be able to ask that you
probably have to send thousand percent
right and so and I want to surprise
these guys yeah so if you're saying
dream podcast guest it's a matter of who
could you get but then who could you
also do the interview with that you want
to do I would do an entire interview
with Barack Obama about the Chicago
Bears like I'd think that I would love
to reduce these like super powerful
people to just fans oh that's great and
only talk about their fandom I'm just
saying it out there for people that have
like never run a podcast before that if
you're like oh how is this person your
your dream guest just think about your
true dream guests and how hard it is to
book that person and then all the levels
of security that go involved in that and
you don't actually have that open
free-flowing conversation guys we've had
guests on here recently and I was told I
can't ask them certain things right and
they're not [ __ ] Barack Obama or
Roger Goodell there you go I mean Obama
at this point he's just so like I'm the
former president I'm in my rights a
booklet on a tour and we get him for
life sure I'm sure he would love to talk
to talk football and not talk politics
for a minute you know like some of the
some of the guys here a bleacher report
that focus on soccer yeah
of talking to American athletes who also
love soccer the Steve Nash's George a
watts of the world because they're so
amped up to talk or like their secret
passion they never get asked about
talking to Obama about Jim McMahon like
get out of here that would be incredible
right
I would love to interview Mark Davis hmm
I am a slightly fascinated by the sons
of franchise owners right or people that
didn't make the money themselves and
dealing with that now I wouldn't
explicitly say it to him like that but
like Mark Davis James Dolan like all
these guys Jim Irsay is someone I would
love to interview and just talk to about
these guitars that he's buying
he seems like he wouldn't be like he
wouldn't ask for the questions in
advance he'd be like all right well
doing this where do I said all right
let's do this let me I weigh the Pat
McAfee stories we talked about her say
is like hey man I just I got this this
Beatles guitar man like it just I would
love that
all right let us go to the IG this is
actually just a compliment the true
chavo just saying the 33% is also in
Denmark keep up the good work thank you
I also asked if you could host any TV
show you want for one show what would it
be easy is it Saturday Night Live Wow
get to be an SNL host you get to do the
monologue you got to be in a couple of
sketches I was going to don't get me
wrong
yeah everybody's a lot I just feel like
will unfortunately be like Oh bankrupt
see that's the reverse between us I'm a
we love and I don't even watch wheel of
fortune
I mean you you should do at some point
in your life you should do family feud
oh because you washing over to the
families with the long microphone be
like now tell me that's all right Karen
here and Karen tell me what do you do
for a living is that your Steve Harvey
no that was I was kind of doing a little
Dawson remember when richard Dawson ah
that would be amazing and I'd like to be
the main host of a good morning football
I just make fun of them the entire no
I'm just kidding I love all those people
no I think SNL is the correct answer
yeah good answer good it's like family
feud put it on the border yes we asked a
hundred people what sure they'd like to
host I got one more here okay
at eight nine four oh four seven eight
seven eight
if you ever wrote down that handle good
for you which QB gets the least
recognition for consistently being great
in the league that's a hard one right so
who teeters on consistently really good
but doesn't get the attention russell
wilson was that guy for a long time and
now he's now i think it's he needed to
have all those other pieces pulled away
from him for people to go wow he can
still do this but for a long time him
and aaron rodgers were the ones
overcoming their own offenses and
dealing with no planning and having to
do it yeah is there anyone that kind of
come i think big ben is a guy that's
taken for granted a lot interesting and
we're gonna see a big test with him this
year without antonio brown there were i
feel like there were some stories last
year of like hey drew brees has been
doing this for 19 years where's his love
you know i think he gets too much and
it's like he gets a ton of love so it it
is it's one of those weird you know
snake eating its own tail stafford is
that guy for me too oh cuz he's awesome
Stafford's one of those guys that when
you talk to actual NFL players they go
man I love Matt Stafford yeah when you
talk to fans that want to talk about
records or comebacks and all that stuff
they're not a fan but the true thing
about Matt Stafford is the offensive
Lions been a mess he got punished but
publicly by having Megatron because
everyone's like how you're not gonna win
with Megatron and it's like I don't know
maybe like the coach none of the coaches
have been good ever like who's the bend
the best offensive coordinator on that
team Jim Bob cooter like that's not even
a joke his name is funny but that's not
his best OC he'll aware but it's yeah I
think Stafford is definitely out there
too I think Matt Ryan was there for a
little bit - yeah it's like once you win
an MVP and you make a super bowl it's a
little tough like everything cuz you
just think of that Super Bowl week when
literally everyone's talking about you
so it's it's hard to really fly into the
radar Phil Rivers never made a Super
Bowl maybe that's something you could
talk about
it's incredible Phil Rivers I mean
unbelievable career numbers truly
unbelievable career numbers and he's won
like a total of five playoff games you
know so is that like an underachieving
career or is he's still an awesome
quarterback that just happened to get
bad luck at the wrong times like I don't
know I don't know what the answer is I
know
because it's like what do you do with
like the Schottenheimer years and then
some of the other coaches they haven't
had success elsewhere we're gonna get to
Mariota and Sonia Michelle in a second
but I want to do this one simp who is
your Mount Rushmore hmm one athlete one
actor or actress one musician and one
miscellaneous oh my god what a fantastic
question
so my athlete is Brian Dawkins do you
have your athlete figured out Michael
Jordan I'm not gonna overthink this one
that's your favorite athlete he's the
number one if I'm making a Mount
Rushmore Mount Rushmore
everything is subjective there is no
yeah so it would have to be Nomar
Garciaparra then say Utley AXA Nomar
Garciaparra thank you he was my number
one athlete you know everyone has their
athlete when they were like 12 13 years
old when they come into the league and
they're yeah guy you know no Maya was my
guy my guy
dude hit 370 always swinging on the
first pitch hitting seventy eight
doubles off the wall you are someone
that has done acting who is the actor or
actress that you're gonna put on your
Mount Rushmore and you can't pick a wife
Tom Hanks Tom Hanks
Tom Hanks there's no other answer my boy
said Tom Hanks like you're about to go
into like a dissertation about Tom Hanks
which you are I can please a good buddy
of mine it was an actor and he worked at
Bubba Gump shrimp right and there's
posters of Tom Hanks all over the wall
and he said the ultimate thing to do
when there is like 10 adults and 10 kids
at a big old you know party table or
five adults five kids whatever the way
to keep the kids silent or keep them
busy for the entire time is just say who
can come up with 30 Tom Hanks movies so
you give them a piece of paper and a
pencil and you have all the kids just
sit there for an hour come up the fact
that kids can name 30 Tom Hanks movies
children can do this the fact that they
can do that says all you need to know
the guys went back-to-back Oscars he can
do comedy he can do serious he's he's
been in everything he produces he writes
he wrote the screenplay for that thing
you do which is one of my favorite music
movies ever made he wrote that
screenplay I'm going with Robert Duvall
I'm just kidding that's fine I don't
have their own thing just to me there's
one answer it's Tom Hanks I am gonna go
I'm looking at either Denzel and Michael
came Mike okay Michael okay just that I
see him I automatically glad when he
talks loudly so it's very loud in Theed
and then your musician prince so you
have a Jordan Tom Hanks Prince you have
a solid Mount Rushmore
well I thought Michael Jordan my bed no
ma yeah okay my musician damn why am I
asking questions and not thinking of the
answers to them I mean we're definitely
being put on the spot in like an hour
from now I'm gonna wake up and be like
oh why didn't I you know Michael Jackson
Michael Jackson you know it's a it's a
it's a tough sell right now when people
are really just hashtag canceling him
after the documentary so but we all
agree his music is unlike it's the
greatest back catalog of maybe any music
maybe Stevie Wonder mmm that's a good
one
and then one miscellaneous I will put
myself you just gonna throw yourself up
there cuz you've always wanted to be on
a rushmore know if you're gonna let me
pick anybody yeah I'm going up there
next to those guys alright now let us
listen in again these interviews are
compliments of Gatorade Gatorade a drink
when you're tired and working out don't
think that's their official slogan but I
don't have it in front of me
so Marcus Mariota Sony Michele
back-to-back interviews hope you guys
enjoy them here are the conversations
with the QB the Titans and the running
back of the Patriots Sony Michele how
are you buddy oh I'm excited to talk to
a Super Bowl champion how does it feel
to hear that pal all the hard work that
I put in this season with my teammates
you know kind of paid off so dude I went
I did a little deep dive on your IG and
I will see man you got some incredible
quotes about hard-working are all these
yours or are you taking them from
someplace no I've taken some some I was
gonna say you're the next prophet man
inky johnson okay that's kind of where I
get my inspiration from my kind
no daily quotes read I felt like hey why
not pass it along you know you know but
I also see after the Super Bowl you you
put out a little mixtape a little rap
song and I also saw in another photo man
you had a whole booth set up there are
we gonna put together an album is the
sony michelle LP gonna be drop at any
time soon you know hey now sony i hear
about a lot of NFL guys that rap i
talked to a lot of them melvin Ingram's
talking to me about his album we know
levy on bail I've seen Colby's Lea where
are you slotting in amongst NFL rappers
right now man I'm not sure I want to
consider myself no rapper okay beautiful
that's really profound I like that
alright so the reason we have sodium
Michelle is because the Gatorade Player
of the Year program he's out there right
now for the festivities the most
prestigious award in high school sports
if you want to get a take a look at it
fans go to Player of the Year Gatorade
dot-com I have a lot of young people
that listen to this podcast man as
you've done this grind and you've kept
going what is something that young
people can kind of put in their mindset
to let them never stop growing and never
stop improving so I think the biggest
things is to understand that dreams
really do come true sometimes they may
seem far-fetched sometimes they may seem
so close but you know it's all about
time and being patient and working hard
you know work hard it will come and I
think it's a this is good advice coming
from a fly guy and I'm curious I see
your brother as a fly guy I see that you
have a fly guy team where does fly guy
come from what age did this start
this started back I mean I was in say
middle school okay being some of my
friends that I grew up with you always
consider ourselves fly hmm
I would say a lot of people you know not
the same so we kindly you know create
this whole I would say Empire of flag
guys I love that and then why are you
fly guide to Stax if I got two stacks
because you know in high school two
thousand yards was my goal love it
ma'am I'm trying to get you two stacks
in the NFL man to stack Stanley that's a
small group one of the guys that did get
two stacks the NFL former Georgia
Bulldog Terrell Davis and do you guys
consider Georgia running back you at
this point I mean lately it's been wild
you girly everything from you know Nick
Chubb and I know you're like the biggest
Nick Chubb fan ever but if you were to
pick out of the recent guys so we're not
including sync which or Charlie trippy
but if we're talking like Chubb Gurley
garrison Hearst Knowshon Moreno even a
Herschel Walker who would be your top
three Georgia running backs and you
could include yourself Sony Michele okay
who's the goat so you have Herschel one
Nick - and who three Todd so do you guys
all look up to Herschel like that is he
just a guy that he walks into the room
and you guys all stop and just call him
the goat I mean there's been running
backs before him yeah guys that we
actually were able to watch
you know he kind of paved that way of
understanding that hey you know you kind
of want to come and eat like Hershel
when you look across the sidelines of
the Superbowl and there's Todd Gurley
another Georgia running back that you
know really well and you're sitting
there on the sidelines is that like a
pinch me moment where you guys were
sitting in the same running back room in
college and you're talking about man one
day we're gonna go the league and now in
your first year your buddies on the
other sideline like that must have been
crazy yeah
surreal experience and the crazy moment
at the same time because it's like man
you understand how hard he worked to get
to that point obviously I will I want to
win the game sure sure he want to do the
same thing but you know somebody got to
come out on top but at the end they kind
of shows us how much work you've put in
did you guys have a side bet or anything
because I would have had a side bet with
my buddy what is what when you met Tom
Brady and you're kind of getting to know
him and all that a lot of people say you
know he's fun guy is he funny has he
ever said anything to you that really
made you laugh um I would say so yeah
it's been a couple times where you know
kind of yeah and it's like dad humor
like I can't even imagine what it's like
ah man violent I mean probably a little
bit of both the dad humor team a humor
yeah
what about Belichick dude is Belichick
ever told a joke in your presence ever
definitely alright can you tell me a
ballot check joke like what's a balichek
joke um see a better take joke is
something I guess no I
nothing you just have to catch it do you
remember the one that you told that you
were told
no not top of my head man I'm trying to
get a Belichick joke it's like my dream
to get a Belichick joke what do you uh
what is grump gonna do in his retirement
ma'am what is it what is a day in the
life of retired Gronk in your mind I'm
not sure know a lot of excitement you
know enjoying enjoying himself when you
win a Super Bowl in your first year it's
got to be a crazy thought because it's
you obviously know that the goal is to
win a Super Bowl every year but it's a
very hard road to take to get here what
do you think the biggest lesson you took
away from winning right away is and then
at the same point how do you battle kind
of the relaxation that comes with
success oh means the good thing is I've
you know throughout the season I've
learned um what it takes to get to that
point it's now I was gonna be smooth
selling we didn't have the best season
hmm had pretty good games we had ups and
downs but I didn't day we kept calling
he kept fighting it took a lot for us to
be able to get to the point where Super
Bowl so now going into year two we
thought about resetting that focus and I
understand we gotta go through the same
things I know I know that you weren't
the only first-round pick for the
Patriots last year and I also know that
you weren't the only Georgia Bulldog
that came out last year and I'm curious
as we start this year and mr. Winn
Isaiah when your former offensive
lineman we haven't got to see him play
you did and I look at this team and I go
man they're getting another first-round
pick because Isaiah's coming back what
kind of a player the Patriots getting
that the rest of the NFL maybe doesn't
know about yet um a guy that no that's
gone that's gonna brain I would say you
know a good piece of his team it's gonna
help this team win a lot of football
games you know he's gonna work hard
that's all you can ask for my player
really I saw one other tweet I'm gonna
end on this where you were kind of
talking about people that were rooting
against the Warriors and you said if
you're rooting against the Warriors I
have to assume that means you're rooting
against the Patriots which let me
realize that you go man when you're on
the team everyone's rooting against you
what is that like to be the the team
that everyone's seemingly rooting
against is it fun I guess so you doing
something right you're on team that's
going something right and um no you
doing something right how many people
like that all right
you are you just heard from a musical
artist that is also a running back from
the New England Patriots
is there a month that we should be on
the lookout for some music Sony Michelle
state Tom all right what and we're
following you on social which is gonna
be fly guy to Stax there we are gonna be
tuned in when you drop it I'm gonna play
it on this podcast and we're gonna do
like a nice album listening party so I'm
very excited all right all right my man
appreciate you brother all right
hello tg4 honey what up Todd good man
I'm gonna tell you the truth I was
texting with my man travel games earlier
and he said now be careful curly is
quick he's got a wit and he's a lot
funnier than you think so I'm very
excited we had gains in the podcast a
few weeks ago and he was only talking
good stuff about you man he better be I
have something I need to admit I went to
Syracuse and the main reason I went to
Syracuse is Carmelo Anthony won the
title and I said I want to go there and
now I'm reading that you're the biggest
Carmelo Anthony fan of all time so I
need to know more about things somebody
came out about that I was like bro I was
like a year ago it's now people want to
talk about it yeah funny whatever
policies have you
have you had a chance to meet Carmelo
yet yeah okay was it like a fan like if
I ever met Brian Dawkins I'd lose my
mind
were you like bro now he's the bro now
yeah where would you like to see him
play next year if he plays but any Los
Angeles team - I was gonna say if he
comes to the Lakers and you're in the
Rams come on now oh that would be
unbelievable
oh I'm be on my game your bro
front row the Lakers game and you'll be
like the only one they are not in an ad
or LeBron Jersey you'll be perfect
oh I'll be the only the only one problem
travell was telling me you're a big-time
music fan man who is in the rotation
right now I'm gonna beat you right now
teacher who else is out some artists
name no cap okay you know anything young
little baby kind of me goes he's a Cali
oblem DJ much time without right now man
so I I just talked to your boy Sony
Michelle another Georgia Bulldog just
tearing it up in the NFL and I asked him
not including like Charlie trippy and
sink which and the really old Georgia
running backs but from like Herschel on
who are his top three and I'm curious
who do you think his top three was and
what's your top three I don't put me on
the plasti taking people with you George
here I'll give you the names Sony
Michele Terrell Davis Knowshon Moreno
garrison Hearst Nick Chubb you Herschel
Walker and you can be on the list if you
want people we don't know based on what
people done it at Georgia though right
uh you can use any criteria you know it
is like I like like I don't know listen
garrison Hurston Knowshon Moreno had
pretty good careers exactly yeah yeah no
sound a great career accident
read it what he'll bow to all right so
what's it gonna be
he went I'll just tell you he went I
think he went you three chub to Garrett
and Herschel Walker one yeah I just put
her Schumann Tobin Sony honestly oh you
guys are very nice to each other
well I saw Sony's like a huge niche at
we can't we can't support their well you
guys are our bu now yeah yeah
what is what does Nick Chubb do so well
that just makes the rest of you guys
love his running style so much he
doesn't want people overrun bad people
I guess plan I look to release my style
mmm like I know you never seen before
ain't good running I know this Swift kid
you guys got a Georgia now man that cake
can cut on a dime Sony's got the agility
you had the flat burner speed and chub
just runs that's what he does oh you do
you're out there right now for the
Gatorade Player of the Year program
again fans can go to Player of the Year
Gatorade calm is the most prestigious
award in high school sports advice for
the next generation I'm sure young
football players come up to you I know
that you and Sony Michelle and and a few
other people you guys do camps and stuff
like that what's your what's your best
advice for young athletes trying to make
it to pro one day I'll keep it
maintained the main thing keep working
hard
I myself with great people who do the
right thing special already you know
even for the kids that's not it there's
a war so just keep working even if
you're not here because you know I
wasn't here yeah um you know on the team
with Gatorade seeing these young
athletes oh and thank you possibly just
keep working I saw you that you tweeted
this before you got your contract about
the difference between NBA and NFL money
I went on a little rant because I
understand there's more players and
there's more
games I get all of that but it's crazy
to me some of the comparisons that
DeAndre Hopkins is three is his contract
is Andrew Wiggins as three DeAndre
Hopkins and that Odell is getting paid
the same as Ian Mahinmi it just blows me
away man I know it's crazy right out of
outlet leave intestines last two years
and I just seen somebody get eighty
million and I couldn't pronounce their
name dude Antonio Brown Tobias Harris
got five times the amount of guaranteed
money as Antonio Brown I liked about
Tobias Harris was the first guy I've
seen I'm like hold on who is this I
started looking this game actually he's
art Oh tonight the last time it didn't
just read up I'm like a I'm a data man
they doing that thing that's all I know
is if I was in high school right now and
I was six five I being gym every day
putting work in the gym I have I have a
left go PR this is when I give out
strategy to people I believe that you
can everyone's talking about your
[ __ ] knee Todd Gurley and everybody
wants to know what's up I think you
should create a social media account
called Todd girlies knee and what you
really want
there's already one a Twitter account
like that dear yes yeah I was gonna say
you can like you could tweet out updates
like your the knee and be like feeling
great today everybody please stop asking
Don about me even if you can't wait
nobody
yeah its media is interesting isn't it
especially because you're in LA maybe
maybe them because like I found myself
doing it either you know I'm doing the
same thing so this is like people period
you know I'm gonna be coming to your
camp a little like in a month or two and
I'm gonna be doing something with Shawn
I'm the one that did the thing with
McVeigh last year where he remembers
like every play
have you have you ever seen him forget
anything before not having this crazy I
don't know how you do it the same I I
wanna like I heard he knows every
person's name in the building from the
Secretary to the janitor you got like an
elephant brain bro an elephant brain
I do love elephants that's pretty good
what about like is he a funny guy to
like I just as Sony of Bill Belichick
tells jokes I gotta go I gotta go
hey man he's a great guy great coach
good and being player's coach low
platform but his memory is business
saying I really can't explain it Todd
keep kicking ass man I appreciate your
time bro thank you appreciate it man
take care
Armand alright so that was sony michelle
and todd gurley brought to you by
Gatorade Player of the Year again Player
of the Year Gatorade calm I'm recording
this so I'm gonna keep recording this so
Jake leave this in before we go back to
me and David again we recorded me and
David earlier in the day about nine
hours ago it's damn near 10 o'clock and
we thought we were gonna get a Mariota
and a Michelle but we got a Michelle
into girly so that's pretty funny but
listen to the two different interviews
do you hear a guy going into a second
year versus a guy going into like year
four or five awesome great time talking
to them Alan running audio staying with
your meet with me late night I
appreciate you pal now let's get back to
the final question of the AMA with David
Inger and myself alright see ya
amazing conversations with Mariota and
our man Sony Michele that one joke that
he told ya great incredible I mean yes
the we all the things you talked about
in that I had no idea when he told that
second story that that happened we're
doing a bit because we haven't actually
heard the conversation yeah no I'm
actually interviewing these guys that
like 9:45 at night cuz they're on the
west coast yeah hopefully they're great
but yeah that that's that anecdote he
told Jim what an anecdote changed my
perception of them going forward
alright so let's end with one more AMA
here yeah this is from Andrew Hines a
great question what was the game
journalist athlete etc that made you
want to pursue
your current career I know it's very
complicated but would love to hear what
made the most impact I'll go first
I think for me I always knew I wanted to
do something in sports yeah like I just
kind of I was like do I want to be an
agent I'm not gonna play you know how
can I do this and so for me I used to
like jokingly do play-by-play I was in
the varsity team for basketball when we
would travel the girls have to play the
JV of play when you have to sit there
and I would just be up in the stands
being like booger-eater passes over to
like whatever and puts it in an A and so
that's when I was like oh I think I can
do this because people be like do it do
it do it and there was a guy in
Philadelphia Comcast SportsNet started
in 1997 so I was 11 and it was 24/7
Philadelphia sports but like most of the
hours was like the fishing Network and
stuff like that but it was the only time
where I was like they're gonna break
down
Eagles training camp today and michael
barkun was this the first host there and
he was openly kind of a philadelphia fan
and it was the first time I had seen
that we're usually you know all they and
I am a journalist MOA law and he was so
like and we're gonna have a great year
and I was like I love that so that's
kind of where like my embracing of being
a fan on TV came from sure I would say
lately I've just been studying Ernie
Johnson just because what happened is
it's like I've always loved inside the
NBA and I've always appreciate it but
really I've just started to learn like
how integral he is to that show so
that's been like the second development
but in terms of like really inspiring me
and wanting to do this Stuart Scott was
huge I was gonna say Stu Scott where you
really I went out of my mouth yeah are
the new expand on Stu Scott - well he I
grew up as this kid that wanted to be a
stand-up comic I don't even know where I
got that interesting my in my brain when
I was like 4 years old I was like
watching premium blend on Comedy Central
you know of that maybe was before that
but it was like comedy specials on HBO
whatever
and I was like I want to do that and in
my mind there was like the very serious
amazing broadcasters that I love like
Bob Costas and then there were the
really funny people on HBO and then
Stuart Scott was like I'm gonna be just
as funny as anyone else that's on TV but
I'm also gonna be talking highlights the
entire time I'm gonna be super
knowledgeable about sports I'm gonna be
just so good at straddling worlds of pop
culture and sports and humor and
excitement and just doing it in his own
way that regardless a lot of people went
out there and tried to be Stuart Scott
that's not the right move that's not
what you take from Stuart Scott no right
and this is true of anyone that's your
hero don't try to become them just take
what they're doing and try to make it
your own so what he was doing was being
this unabashed self that we'd never seen
on TV before and that's what I wanted to
do I was like how do I find what I want
to do distill that into my own version
of the thing that I'm excited to bring
to the world my mom used to say that I
would sit there and watch Chris Berman
mmm and would go I'm gonna do that and I
think cuz Chris Berman and Stuart Scott
Stuart Scott had like phrases that he
would say that just sounded so [ __ ]
cool yeah
and Chris Berman when he would give a
guy a nickname I was like I just it just
it drew me in because I wanted to come
up with nicknames and I was like how did
he come up with that and and he these
were guys that they got to ESPN at such
a young age at such a young development
of that company right that they were
able to put so much of their mark on it
and then all the people that kind of
came after them had to exist in more
confined lanes but they always felt
bigger than everything and I loved that
because it felt unabashedly then yeah
and I think what the advice you just
gave about figure out what people do I
hear this from people all the time you
know I want to I want to do what you do
and stuff and it's if you don't only
listen to yourself you're just gonna
copy people right and so it's that I
think it's great advice for everybody is
look at the people that you admire study
them but then you eventually have to
stop watching them or else you're only
going to continue to copy their path you
need to figure out
their core like you said what is the
reason that they resonate with you and
then stop listening to anybody because
it doesn't matter if your favorite
comedian is Dave Chappelle or if it's
Richard Pryor or if it's Chris Rock or
if it's Dave Attell like the thing that
binds them all as some of the greatest
comedians is that they're earnest
they're raw yeah they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't take notes on their act and
surely original they're truly original
and only they could do their own
material cuz it's about their own life
their own experience and that's the
thing you should take you shouldn't say
I want to be Dave Attell you say I want
to do the thing that he does but for
myself but that's why they're so special
and that's why they're so amazing sire
some people are so special that they hit
like Prince you hit who you are so on
the barrel and it's so captivating that
people abandon their own dreams to help
you follow yours mmm
that you're you've nailed it so well
that people gravitate to your dream
instead of their own yeah that's a wild
[ __ ] but that's because none of us know
why we're here right and we all just
want to have purpose and really your
purpose is love and as again serious but
you're not man but just it's about it's
about spending time with people that you
love and that you care about and
achieving whatever it is that fuels your
fire man yeah and and don't let anyone
distract you from that [ __ ] I love it
all right thanks again - Mario -
Michelle those stories are gonna go
viral anchor man excited to be in Lake
Tahoe with you oh so excited and then as
the YouTube show begins to develop more
homies more information with more
information coming out little pieces
once at a time I mean I might even be
doing like media tours for this kind of
stuff nice I have to get down like my
one-story elevator pitch you my my
elevator pitch and then also the one
story that I tell - all the talk shows
mm-hmm oh man there's one time all right
play that music Nicholas thank you -
audio Nick always hold it down Thank You
Jake for edit
and put some time codes up thank you to
David Egan for holding it down pinks
we're gonna be on the road and thank you
to you guys the homies a 33% you're the
main reason we do this [ __ ] holla holla
holla holla holla holla we'll see
[Music]